rafik ferroviaire très perturbé en
bretagne par les barrages des
agriculteurs le premier ministre recevra
les dirigeants bretons vendredi helmut
kohl en visite officielle en israël
le chancelier ouest-allemand accueilli
par des manifestants
ils ont tressé de neige importantes
mesures de sécurité pour l'ouverture à
paris du procès des quatre terroristes
arméniens qui avaient attaqué le
consulat de turquie en 1981 paris à
l'heure de louisiane le film conçu pour
le cinéma et pour antenne 2 sort demain
dans les seuls un monsieur bonsoir ce
qui balaie l'actualité ce soir une
actualité pourtant bien nourrie c'est la
tempête
la tempête qui sévit sur l'ouest et le
nord de l'europe et qui tuent les marins
en sont les premières victimes
ainsi dans la manche un cargo battant
pavillon libérien a coulé ce matin près
de l'île de guernesey
bilan 15 morts trois disparus et neuf
rescapés sur les lieux du drame
hervé brusini 4h30 ce matin sur le port
de guernesey
le bateau de sauvetage de l'île des
soeurs williams arnold vient de rentrer
avec à son bord neuf rescapés
l'alerté a été donnée quelques heures
plus tôt par le cargo libérien en avarie
après une voie d'eau dues à l'arrachage
d'un panneau de cannes les supporteurs
d'escadre français casabianca ainsi
qu'un patrouilleur britanniques et deux
hélicoptères de la royal navy se sont
immédiatement portés sur les lieux des
appareils de l'aéronavale pris dans les
orages ont dû rebrousser chemin alors
que les premiers bâtiments à les rallier
le cargo en perdition le radium med
s'est retournée seule une dizaine
d'hommes en état de choc et transie de
froid était récupéré par le william
arnold le second du bateau de sauvetage
ratée
de trouvant une petite barque
j'avais tragédie petit dj wiwi boma avec
disons qu'ils ont donné la vie tous
vivent non non
neuf biberon 1 est morte parce qu'on
dirait ma bulle cannoise sauvetage de
ménez on passait notre la ville hôte
côté le petit parc et j'ai beaucoup de
favoris qui vais les hommes les hommes
chez nous parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
de vagues cette ville mais aussi la
légende dont l'intérieur très fatigué
très fatigué cette fois je vois c'est un
système d'accroché l'école
ce soir une vingtaine d'heures après ce
naufrage il n'y a pratiquement plus
d'espoir de retrouver les trois marins
portés disparus malgré les recherches
sur jaune durant toute la journée de
nombreux navires les neuf rescapés du
cargo libérien ont été hospitalisés à
guernesey ici à l'hôpital
ils sont en train l'abri suis athée sont
ici placé sous surveillance médicale
continue les six autres sont bien en
fait tous les neuf sont dans un état
satisfaisant depuis la nuit dernière les
îles anglo normandes sont isolées par
voie maritime du continent
seuls quelques avions réussi à se poser
aujourd'hui à guernesey
la tempête continuait sur les côtes les
sauveteurs restent en alerte et d'autres
bateaux sont en difficulté dans la
manche et en mer du nord
les côtes françaises et suit elle aussi
la tempête et dans d'autres régions du
pays les pluies et la neige provoque des
perturbations gérant de boeny les côtes
françaises de l'atlantique et de la
manche ont été balayés cette nuit et
aujourd'hui par de violentes tempêtes à
granville dans la manche le vent
soufflait cet après midi à 110 km/heure
et il y a eu dans le nord du cotentin
des pointes jusqu'à 170 km/heure de
nombreuses communes ont été privés
d'électricité
caves inondées véranda brisé porteuse
arrachés on ne compte plus les dégâts
matériels provoqués par la tempête
notamment à être ta
tempête également sur la côte bretonne
et la côte atlantique
dans le sud-ouest les rafales de vent
dépasser cette nuit les 100 kilomètres
heure les marins du golfe de gascogne
ont dû rester aura un mauvais temps qui
a touché aussi la grande bretagne en
écosse la neige paralysant le pays
depuis une semaine a fait neuf morts
principalement des personnes âgées
isolées et des alpinistes
deux militaires qui escalade et les
mondes cannes gorn au nord de l'ecosse
sont portées disparues et les recherches
pour les retrouver ont dû être
interrompues train bloqué route devenue
impraticable
des centaines de conducteurs ont dû
abandonner leur véhicule pour trouver
refuge chez l'habitant
des milliers de foyers sont privés
d'électricité et de téléphone tempête
également en mer du nord où le vent a
soufflé au large jusqu'à force 11
l'hiver un peu tardif cette année est
bien là et dans toute sa vigueur
alain gillot-pétré nous dira en fin de
journal ce qu'il faut attendre du temps
de demain des barrages sur les voies
ferrées ont enrayé toute la journée le
trafic ferroviaire en bretagne malgré
l'intervention en plusieurs endroits des
forces de l'ordre les agriculteurs
bretons sont donc passés à l'action
après l'incarcération de l'un de leurs
dirigeants syndicaux et ce malgré
l'invitation du premier ministre et du
ministre de l'agriculture monsieur
rocard de recevoir jeudi les dirigeants
des organisations syndicales nationales
et monsieur mauroy a convié vendredi à
matignon les présidents du conseil
régional du comité économique et social
et de la chambre d'agriculture de
bretagne qui lui vient de décliner
l'invitation
aujourd'hui calmejane un suivi dans la
région de rennes
la journée d'action des agriculteurs
bretons 11h ce matin à la gare de
châteaubourg à 25 kilomètres de rennes
un des six points choisis par les
agriculteurs pour interrompre toute
circulation de trains en bretagne ici ce
sont des camions de coopératives qui
s'installe sur le ballast les
agriculteurs présents sont peu nombreux
ils ont prévu de se relayer toutes les
six heures parmi eux guy gardant jeunes
agriculteurs de 31 ans il y a 6 ans il
s'est installé ici près de vitré en ille
et vilaine sur une exploitation de 16
hectares sur laquelle aujourd'hui il
élève des vaches laitières
lui est persuadé que comme pour les deux
tiers des agriculteurs dans quelques
années il sera chômeur c'est surtout
pour cela qu'il a tenu à venir
manifester aujourd'hui à châteaubourg
sur la photo booth et c'est uniquement
fazila presque uniquement parce que
l'agriculture telle que moi je vais à
fait aujourd'hui sur 16 hectares de
surface agricole utile avec trente
vaches laitières
c'est quelque chose on est en train de
nous condamner à mort mon arrière grand
père il était paysan
mon grand père il était cultivateur mon
père il était agriculteur
voilà je suis exploitants agricoles et
mon fils y sera chômeur dans ce genre de
manifestation les agriculteurs sont bien
organisés ils ont prévu des brigades
d'intervention volante qui à tout moment
peuvent parer les voies ferrées en
d'autres endroits que les six points
prévus à l'origine
et ce malgré le gros déploiement des
forces de l'ordre ici par exemple à
saint jean sur vilaine
ils ont déposé sur la voie une benne
chargé de vingt tonnes d'aliments pour
bétail
cela a eu pour effet d'arrêter le train
paris brest en pleine campagne où nous
on est retardée maintenant c'est une
façon pour eux s'expriment et s'ils sont
acculés à faire ça dans thérèse
pour moi c'est que les gens en pâtissent
les responsables agricoles ont assuré
qu'ils tiendront le rail sans violence
pour éviter tout affrontement
les brigades volantes d'agriculteurs ont
reçu comme consigne de se replier en
d'autres points de la voie ferrée en cas
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
malgré le gros déploiement des crs sur
tout le réseau ferroviaire breton
un agriculteur me confier de toute façon
ils ne pourront jamais mettre un
gendarme derrière chaque agriculteur
n'est en d'autres endroits comme à saint
jacut les pins dans le morbihan
les affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et les manifestants ont été plus
brutaux le centre national des jeunes
agriculteurs annoncé son intention de
passer à l'action dès demain dans les
différentes régions françaises en
multipliant les démarches officielles
auprès des préfets afin de réclamer la
mise en liberté de jean jacques ricou
vice président de la fédération
départementale du finistère en prison à
nantes depuis dimanche à la suite de la
mise à sac de la sous-préfecture de
brest à l'appel des partis de gauche et
des syndicats
quelques 2500 personnes ont manifesté ce
soir à brest pour protester contre la
mise à sac jeudi dernier de la sous
préfecture
nul ne peut espérer résoudre des
problèmes régionaux ou catégoriels par
le recours à la violence tous ceux qui
se rendront coupables d'actes de
violence caractérisée seront interpellés
et poursuivis
c'est ce qu'a déclaré ce matin le
premier ministre pierre mauroy qui avait
réuni laissant rien commissaire de la
république des départements et des
régions
au ministère de l'intérieur en présence
de messieurs de fer et de l'or monsieur
roy a rappelé au préfet que le maintien
de l'ordre et la première de leurs
responsabilités il leur a aussi demandé
de se mobiliser pour lutter contre
l'inflation et le chômage dans leurs
régions respectives et les menaces de
chômage dans la construction navale ont
amené aujourd'hui à paris quelques 3000
travailleurs des chantiers navals nord
méditerranée venus de dunkerque de la
scène et de la ciotat et en fin d'après
midi le secrétaire d'état à la mer
ils en gagnent à préciser les intentions
du gouvernement en matière de
construction navale
serge me serais et à la nourrice qui
touche aux camps de thil pourtant ce
n'est pas spécialement le cas ce matin
dans les rues de paris où ils sont
plusieurs milliers de dunkerque de la
scène et de la ciotat
si les rues registre venus clamer leur
colère contre le patronat mais aussi
leurs inquiétudes devant la politique de
restructuration industrielle
manifestation unitaire puisque tous les
syndicats sont représentés un seul
slogan pas de licenciements les jeunes
sont initiés c'est naturel la direction
a annoncé m 3 et 6 me le dise en
dessinant et fermeture le site cherche à
couler lakafia lapeyre
quand vous dites ils cherchent à couler
les actes de qui parlez-vous
gouvernement pour moi dépassé il sait
pas ce qu'il veut que six ans grâce à la
mi-journée les manifestants se regrouper
devant la direction des chantiers nord
méditerranée là une délégation était
reçue par la direction
un peu plus tard une autre délégation
intersyndicale a été reçue pendant plus
d'une heure et demie par le secrétaire
d'état à la mer
les chantiers auront des commandes et
l'état avant subventionner ces commandes
dans une fourchette qui va entre 260 et
280 milles tonneaux de jauge brute
compenser ce sont 1 des assurances
qu'ils ont été données par le ministre
de la mer par le ministre de la mer et
la deuxième assurances pas de fermeture
de site et pas de licenciements c'est à
dire pas de chômeurs dans ce cadre il
n'y aura pas de licenciement qui
impliquerait une mise en chômage pure et
simple de toutes les mesures qui sont
étudiées actuellement par le
gouvernement
qu'il s'agisse de congé de reconversion
qu'il s'agisse de toutes les mesures
sociales que nous connaissons que ces
mesures seraient appliquées dans les
chantiers navals 18h30 après avoir tenté
de se rendre à l'hôtel matignon le
cortège se regroupent aux invalides où
la manifestation prend fin sans aucun
incident dans notre dernier journal à
23h30 un débat sur la situation dans la
construction navale opposera le député
communiste
edmond garcin à l'udf pascal clément le
secrétaire général de la cgt henri
krasucki qui était tout à l'heure la vie
tu es d'antenne de midi a souligné
l'enjeu que représente pour son syndicat
la construction navale et il a lancé une
forme d'avertissement ce sujet au
gouvernent il ya une volonté il y aura
des voies pour des solutions il faut
qu'il y ait cette volonté et pour que
cette volonté se se produise il faut
effectivement que les travailleurs s'en
mêle aujourd'hui c'est très important
cette journée c'est la première fois
depuis 1981 que les ferrailleurs d'une
branche
et dans ces conditions la vienne à paris
ça rappelle quelque chose
ça devrait faire réfléchir du monde et
il dit viennent dans l'unité de toutes
leurs organisations syndicales des
entreprises
c'est très important et c'est très bien
je m'en félicite mais nous n'avons cessé
de dire depuis deux ans rien ne se fera
sans l'action syndicale de masse des
travailleurs
elle a lieu il faut la prendre en
considération pour la troisième fois
depuis le début de l'année un enseignant
originaire du continent a été visé par
un attentat en corse
sa villa près d'ajaccio était en
herman détruite par l'explosion isabelle
bechler robert bertrand professeur
d'éducation physique à ajaccio avait
quitté sa maison de coraux avec ses
enfants depuis 20 minutes seulement
quand la villa a été soufflée par
l'explosion
d'après la police trois charges avait
été placée à l'intérieur même de la
maison
l'attentât a été signée de plusieurs
tracts du fln était la famille bertrand
était installé dans le village depuis
1914 et d'aucune menace d' aucun coup de
téléphone absolument de rien et jusqu'à
présent j'entretenais même avec certains
collègues ou certaines personnes du
voisinage des relations cordiales je dis
bien des personnes nationaliste avec des
jets nationaliste je pense être un homme
de dialogue et je n'ai jamais eu à
prendre parti pour ou contre ces
situations sinon bien sûr contre la
violence celle ci étant j'étais petit
j'étais inquiet c'est sûr je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'étais inquiet j'avais un
voisin monsieur kabila qui avec qui
j'entretenais des bons termes vous savez
qu'il a donc il est du flnc qu'il a ce
qu avec une bombe
sa disparition m'a profondément émue m'a
profondément troublée sur le plan de
l'homme je l'apprécié beaucoup
et aujourd'hui je retrouve des tracts
avec son effigie son visage en dix ans
et voilà il faut payer la mort de cet
homme qui en fait était non pas mon ami
mais qui allait peut-être devenir un ami
il est quelqu'un que j'estime et que je
respecte et alors je ne comprends plus
dès aujourd'hui un grand nombre
d'enseignants de l'île ont tenu à
manifester leur solidarité à robert
bertrand dernière une grève de cinq
jours avait été observée pour protester
contre la violence dans les lycées corse
atmosphère survoltée cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale les députés
convoqué en session extraordinaire cet
effet ont commencé l'examen du projet de
loi sur la presse qui devrait durer deux
semaines
la séance a été suspendue deux fois cet
après midi le secrétaire d'état à la
communication georges fillioud ayant
tenu en ouvrant le débat
des propos jugés insultants par
l'opposition jean-louis le scène
pour le début de cette session
extraordinaire le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que le spectacle n'était pas
à la hauteur de la fiche affligeant at
on même entendus dans les couloirs
l'opposition s'est efforcé de retarder
le lever de rideau avec des rappels au
règlement qui n'avait rien à voir avec
le débat sur la presse
on a parlé des agriculteurs bretons de
la modification de la loi électorale
pour 86 ou encore du signataire réel des
ordonnances de 44 bref à droite on
faisait patienter
à gauche on s'impatientait pourtant à la
conférence des présidents jean claude
gaudin avait proposé au monde l'udf un
gentleman ce agreements selon lequel
l'opposition renonceraient à une
obstruction dur un débat qui s'annonce
est serein donc c'était compter sans
georges fillioud qui dès qu'il a eu la
parole n'a pas hésité à jeter de l'huile
sur le feu la commission des affaires
culturelles familiales et sociales en
raison de l'obstruction systématique de
la droite a dû siéger pendant cent
quarante quatre heures pour examiner les
quarante deux articles de ce projet de
loi
record absolu toutes catégories de noir
et tout république confondues
vous pouvez messieurs vinci serré je
pense et je suis sûr qu'elle au peuple
jugera à ce qu'ils valent c'est qu'il me
représentant là monsieur fillion l'at-il
fait exprès toujours est il que les
députés de l'opposition unanime ceux ci
sont issus d'un député autres et
guillemet et on réagit aux contres ou
d'un ministre qui remettait en cause
leur représentativité
eh bien je dis que c'est une injure que
de dire que nous sommes des
représentants du peuple entre guillemets
car nous sommes les représentants du
peuple
depuis le début du débat sur la presse
on peut constater que le président
d'assemblée louis mermaz temporise
parfois même en faveur de l'opposition
à croire que cette loi pose réellement
problème aux élus de quelque bord qu'ils
soient
pour la majorité une chose est sûre dans
l'état actuel du texte
les communistes s'abstiendront et seuls
les socialistes voteront l'opposition
refuse donc de participer à la
discussion générale qui s'achèvera cette
nuit et dans les couloirs les députés
socialistes et les radicaux de gauche
désapprouvait les propos de georges
fillioud par ailleurs la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale a mis
sur pied aujourd'hui la mission
d'information sur les aspects financiers
de la sphère des avions renifleurs
politique encore avec l'annulation par
le conseil d'état des élections
municipales des tempes pour
irrégularités commises par le candidat
communiste élu pendant la campagne
l'émission politique d'antenne de
l'heure de vérité avec pour invité le
président du front national jean-marie
le pen a journée d'une semaine à la
demande unanime du conseil
d'administration de notre chaîne
l'émission avait été programmée pour le
6 février jour du 50e anniversaire des
manifestations de 1934 elle aura lieu le
13 janvier un report que le front
national juge grands textes
le journaliste jean durieux toujours en
prison la chambre d'accusation de la
cour d'appel de paris rendra demain son
arrêt sur la demande de mise en liberté
du rédacteur en chef de paris match qui
sera interrogé une nouvelle fois par le
juge d'instruction qu'il avait incarcéré
jeudi dernier pour vol et recel de vol
des photos de la victime du japonais
cannibale le palais de justice de paris
transformée en camp retranché
aujourd'hui pour l'ouverture du procès
des quatre terroristes arméniens qui en
septembre 80 avaient attaqué le consulat
de turquie à paris tuant un garde le
turc et blessant un consul d'emblée et
c'était bien l'objectif des accusés le
génocide arménien est devenu le centre
des débats
paul lefebvre et dominique tierces
plus d'une centaine de ses rêves de
garder nos vies les deux gendarmes
avaient pris place ce matin autour du
palais de justice et cela fait près
d'une semaine que toutes les entrées
sont strictement contrôlés visiteurs et
habitués doivent présenter leurs papiers
d'identité ou leur carte professionnelle
chaque sac à main chaque serviette et
scrupuleusement fouillé la police a
multiplié depuis quelques jours ces
rondes autour du palais la circulation
dans certaines rues avoisinantes est
interdite et toutes les voitures en
stationnement sont inspectés à
l'intérieur tous les recoins sont
systématiquement passés au peigne fin
seuls quelques dizaines de personnes ont
accès à la salle d'audience
des mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles
maintenant jusqu'à la fin du procès dans
les yeux
les voici les quatre jeunes net les
psychiatres diront intelligent lucide
responsable tout de suite une
déclaration politique
notre peuple a été dispersée et
massacrés par les turcs
notre terre est occupée par les turcs
nous sommes un peuple
donc nous avons le droit de vivre en
orient nous sommes persécutés en
occident nous risquons l'assimilation
donc la disparition
et puis il ajoute et les jurés sont
attentifs pendant 60 ans nous avons
lutter pacifiquement pour faire
reconnaître nos droits
personne même vous n'a écouté pendant
deux générations alors distille seule la
lutte armée peut briser abattre le mur
de silence et l'indifférence
henri verneuil l'arménien écrire à la
colère des entrailles
à force bascule dans la violence bon et
pourquoi la france
réponse nous avons attaqué des turcs pas
des français bien sûr depuis 79 les
choses et la politique ont changé la
salle a aussi d'ailleurs
et ces quatre hommes aujourd'hui sont
apparus un peu comme des premiers
communion du terrorisme mais le
président floch a dit je ne veux pas
entendre ce mot le procès n'est pas
jugée c'est un autre génocide que le
génocide arménien génocide autrement
reconnu par l'histoire est infiniment
présent dans les mémoires qui pèsent sur
la visite officielle que le chancelier
helmut kohl a entreprise aujourd'hui en
israël
onze ans après willy brandt helmut kohl
est le 2ème chancelier ouest-allemand
affronter une épreuve politique et
psychologique délicate sur place en
israël
michel meyer enfants socialement
mémorial de l'holocauste
l'ombre de six millions de victimes du
génocide nazi le symbole des
culpabilités responsabilité allemande
le phoque du confrontation renouvelé
entre l'allemagne de l'holocauste et
celle de nick folle celle d'une
génération venue en israël
consciente des têtes d'historique des
allemands envers les juifs mais refusant
la notion de faute de culpabilité
personnelle en conséquence fait coller
au delà des émotions une attitude plus
détaché que celle des français disent à
de noël kudrin helmut kohl n'avait que
15 ans en 1945 il parle plus aisément de
long historique que de culpabilité
collective ce genre de nuances les
israéliens ils l'ont montré aujourd'hui
encore dans la rue ne sont pas prêts à
les accepter
je proteste contre cette saisie dans ces
conditions là quand il vient ici nous
demander que nous acceptions tout ce qui
se passe maintenant en allemagne
c'est à dire la réhabilitation des
néonazis l'arabisation délit ad des
anciens waffen ss
il ne peut y avoir de normalisation dans
le sens habituel du terme entre
allemands et israéliens
pourtant elle me colle arrivent ici avec
un souci d'émancipation la volonté de
réaliser une sorte d' équilibre dans ses
relations avec israël et le monde arabe
entre juifs et arabes
d'évidence cette volonté est admis par
messieurs famille à la condition qu'il
n'y ait pas des d'allemands ostensible
aux arabes
d'entrée le premier israélien a donc
évoqué très directement l'intention
allemande de vendre des armes à l'arabie
saoudite
un projet inacceptable même si le char
léopard 2 ne fait pas partie de la
panoplie promise aux saoudiens
entretiens cordiaux donc dans la forme
mais intraitable sur le fond au moins du
côté israélien
dernière minute près d'une semaine après
le discours glacial à stockholm de son
ministre des affaires étrangères le
numéro un du kremlin youri andropov
répond par le biais de l'agent stage à
l'offre de reprise du dialogue soviéto
américaine offre faite avant la
conférence de stockholm par le président
reagan les la porte du kremlin est
ouverte dit
agence incitant le numéro un soviétique
la porte du kremlin est ouverte si les
discussions conduisent à des accords
concrets
fin de citation les marines américains
resteront à beyrouth le président reagan
l'a réaffirmé aujourd'hui à l'intention
des parlementaires américains qui sont
de plus en plus nombreux à demander le
retrait du contingent américain de la
force multinationale au maroc après les
émeutes sanglantes de ces derniers jours
la situation est complètement rentré
dans l'ordre selon le ministère marocain
de l'intérieur
mais à nador dans le rif au nord-ouest
du pays une grève de protestation contre
la répression serait partiellement
suivie notre envoyé spécial patricia
cost vient de rentrer de nador dont tous
les journalistes avaient été expulsées
elles ramènent les premières images de
ces émeutes dont les victimes ont été
essentiellement des enfants
voici les premières photos prises à
nador lors du déclenchement des émeutes
ces images imparfaite et parcellaire
montre quand même plan après plan
l'arrestation par l'armée marocaine d'un
adolescent ces adolescents de 10 à 15
ans qui ont été à l'origine des troubles
ce jeune a été arrêtés mais certains de
ses amis sont déjà morts sous les balles
de ces mêmes militaires qui n'ont pas
voulu employer des grenades lacrymogènes
en effet dès le début pour disperser les
émeutiers ils ont tiré dans la foule et
s'est auto mitrailleuses blindés ont
même été utilisé à nador les habitants
estime à 40 le nombre des morts un
français de passage dans la ville a
assisté à ces manifestations
il a accepté de témoigner à condition de
ne pas être reconnu sa famille est
toujours à nador à propos des victimes
pouvons simplement certifié qu'il n'y en
eu plusieurs dizaines au moins plusieurs
dizaines de morts
de nombreux blessés mais quant aux
déclarations de certains journalistes
étrangers il ya beaucoup d'exagération
évidemment il n'y a pas eu de pendu dans
les rues de nador il n'y a pas eu
d'hélicoptère qui a tiré à la
mitrailleuse lourde sur les manifestants
mais de toute façon ils veulent quand
même eu beaucoup de victimes puisque
l'armée a tiré
lorsqu'elle a repris les quartiers du
centre à tirer systématiquement sur tout
ce qui bougeait écoutez je ne peux pas
être affirmatif il ya certainement eu
des enfants il ya eu des adultes aussi
beaucoup de blessés ont été sont morts
ont décédé à l'hôpital de nador rien
vous affirmez sur ce plan-là ya eu des
dizaines de morts ça c'est des sources
que confidentiel mais sur elle plusieurs
dizaines environ 30 40 peut-être une
cinquantaine de moore et surtout
plusieurs centaines de blessés
l'armée aujourd'hui a littéralement
investi la petite ville à chaque détour
de rue on peut voir ces camions avec des
militaires l'armé au pied
faisant face à la population c'est gamin
insouciant ont le même âge que ceux qui
ont participé aux manifestations
ils ont été filmés quelques heures avant
la grève générale d'hier grève
parfaitement respecté à nador au
lendemain du discours du roi qui ici n'a
pas semblé convaincre
près d'une semaine après les émeutes
l'armée est encore omniprésente
la population n'a pas d'autre solution
pour l'instant que de s'habituer à cette
force déployée qui fait régner
maintenant l'ordre la qualité précaire
de ces images tournées en super 8 sont
liés ou circonstances difficiles qui
préside au travail des journalistes
notre envoyé spécial au sommet de
casablanca gers bague a été entendu
pendant quatre heures aujourd'hui par la
police marocaine qui a confisqué tout ce
public
les jeux olympiques à paris en 1992 le
président mitterrand en a confirmé la
possibilité aujourd'hui en allant
visiter à vincennes l'institut national
des sports paris viii
à l'heure de la louisiane et de ses cris
le nine crinoline les combats guerrier
et amoureux de la guerre de sécession
qui font palpiter les livres de maurice
denuzière font maintenant l'objet d'un
film franco canadien coproduit par
antenne 2 le film sort demain dans les
salles obscures
la première a lieu ce soir en présence
du gouverneur de la louisiane qui a été
reçu ce matin par le chef de l'état et
du maire de la nouvelle orléans france
roche bien sûr a vu le film en avant
première le bateau à aubes sur le
mississippi est fait dans la plantation
sur les pelouses devant la véranda
blanche de la maison coloniale les
capelines les ombrelles les belles de la
nouvelle orléans et puis tout à côté les
cases des esclaves noirs qui cueille le
coton en chantant le mas ne rit pas des
esclaves qui sont tendus ou pris en
chasse par leurs maîtres cruel et puis
la guerre de sécession acharnée entre
nordistes et sudistes enfin d amour
aussi torride que la température c'est
louis diable
les coureurs de tout comme jean du
connaît mais n'ont jamais refusé de
passer une nuit avec moi
d'après cette lettre adrien tomas matin
j'aurais aimé mal et je serais parti pas
de vapeur siglé je serais parti pour
devant
j'ai simplement la bougeotte et des
comptes propose quelque chose qui se
passe ou que ce soit loin de chez moi je
me précipite et là je dois dire qu'il y
avait une expérience de plus étaient
tournés en plus dans une langue qui met
tout de même étrangères je prétends ne
le répétez à personne surtout ce que je
prétends être bilingue mais c'est pas
vrai du tout en fait jamais rien que
j'ai jamais compris un rouleur mais sa
vedette margot kidder l'ex fiancée de
superman ne lui en 5 8 et je voudrais il
a épousé à la fin du tournage dans un an
son anglais sera digne de shakespeare
oui il pas mal anglais le matin j'ai pas
mal français d'après midi le soir et la
nuit
alors vous arrivez à discuter à l'heure
du déjeuner déjeuner c'est difficile
commencez par faire le film et puis
après on n'a pas eu envie de se séparer
c'est la première fois pour moi que j'ai
joué une dame grande lady en anglais du
général j'ai joué les députés les
alcooliques les mines promènera les
femmes comme ça
une led et qui n'a pas froid aux yeux et
n'hésite pas à 20 ans a incendié sa
propre maison et à 50 à faire le coup de
feu elle même entre temps elle
collectionne mariam ans dans un contexte
de mention de 20 filles avec les morts
violentes nécessaire à tout mélodrame
qui se respecte
philippe de broca spécialistes la
comédie a fait avec le diable son
premier drame romantique
je le dis tout de suite à ma roue et aux
autres comedia surtout ne faut pas
pleurer il faut pas dépasser pour que le
pour que le spectacle soit soit touchant
touchant je veux dire et même mêmes
bouleversa enfin je pense qu'il fallait
effectivement le faire avec beaucoup de
retenue et d'élégance est ce que vous
imaginez à chaque passe en ce moment
précis
sortie demain dans les salles
parlons maintenant du temps alain
gillot-pétré ben ça ne s'arrange pas le
temps est absolument impitoyable la
météo nationale nous annonce deux
tempêtes enfin deux tempêtes deux
dépressions d'ici la fin de la semaine
regarder la première à élite ici elle va
se développer elle arrivera demain par
par l'ouest du pays
regardez maintenant la carte en un coup
d'oeil ce repas une trop mauvaise
journée dans l'ensemble avec encore un
peu d'instabilité les averses de pluie
ou de neige notamment sur le nord-est le
matin mais ça se tassera attention au
verglas aussi il va geler au sol
toujours un fort risque d'avalanches sur
les pyrénées surtout sur les alpes du
nord mais il y aura aussi de très belles
éclaircies
hélas la pluie reviendra l'après-midi
par l'ouest notamment elle sera plus
active sur le sud-ouest où ça commence à
déborder nous allons aux inondations
s'ils continuent à pleuvoir aussi
longtemps et aussi fort un coup d'oeil
sur les températures de 4 à 9 degrés sur
la moitié nord et de 5 à 14 degrés sur
la moitié sud et températures qui seront
en hausse et une sorte de redoux demain
mercredi 25 janvier deux minutes de
soleil en plus le 8h30 coucher 17h35
c'est le dernier cas petit quartier de
lune profit des zambiens et fêter les
pôles à 23h30 c'est hervé claude qui
vous présentera notre dernière édition
de ma 12h45 antennes 2010 18h36 la vie à
demain 20h très bonne soirée sur antenne